[Música]
vamos a ver cuáles son los hechos más
destacados de la jornada en términos
económicos está con nosotros jorge
hurtado comenzamos hablando de esa
última reunión de la reserva federal de
eeuu que evidenciaron las minutas de
este encuentro bueno la decisión de
continuar subiendo los tipos de interés
durante los próximos meses para tratar
de controlar la elevada inflación en ese
país se confirma aunque podría ser de
forma un poco más moderada una decisión
que la fed a como también se conoce el
banco central estadounidense espera
tomar mientras ve cómo reacciona el
mercado con las recientes subidas de los
tipos de interés tan sólo el pasado 27
de julio
la reserva federal aprobó la cuarta
subida consecutiva de los tipos de
interés y la segunda consecutiva de 75
puntos básicos pese a la decisión de
considerar bajar las tasas en algún
momento por lo menos para septiembre no
se descarta otro aumento de los tipos de
interés de forma drástica o en los tipos
de interés si la inflación continúa
subiendo a como lo ha venido haciendo en
los últimos meses la más reciente subida
de los tipos o de la mayor economía del
mundo pasó a situarse en el rango de
entre el 2,25
y el 25 por ciento porque hablemos de la
canasta básica en chile- que sigue
aumentando de precio mes a mes así bueno
la canasta básica alcanzó el mayor
incremento anual desde que se tiene
registro alguno el precio llegó por
primera vez a los 645 dólares lo que
supuso un incremento interanual del 20,6
por ciento hay que destacar que el 84
por ciento de los 80 productos que
componen la canasta básica chilena
sufrieron un aumento de precios
productos como el plátano la zanahoria y
la merluza que es un tipo de pescado
bastante consumido allá fueron los que
presentaron las principales alzas la
canasta básica es una de las variables
que el ministerio de desarrollo social
monitorea para fijar la línea de la
pobreza y la pobreza extrema en ese país
la inflación en chile ha estado elevada
desde hace varios meses chile acumuló un
aumento de 85 por ciento de enero a
julio de este año y del 13,1 por ciento
en los últimos 12 meses es la cifra más
alta desde
1994 hablemos ahora de nicaragua su país
jorge qué pasó con la economía de este
país centroamericano bueno el gobierno
de nicaragua anunció un programa de
crédito para potenciar la producción
rural en el que se destinarán al menos
75 7 millones de dólares el proyecto
denominado adelante busca que miles de
pequeños productores que contribuyen al
crecimiento y desarrollo del campo
puedan acceder a financiamiento para sus
proyectos desde el sector agropecuario
hasta la industria manufacturera este
proyecto que tienen mira a efectuarse en
los próximos tres años es para
beneficiar a cerca de 182 mil personas
de las cuales por lo menos cinco mil
recibirán desembolsos de entre 278
dólares en 1.600 dólares hay que
destacar que este anuncio llega mientras
el país espera aprovechar las relaciones
con china luego de haber firmado en
julio el acuerdo de cosecha temprana y
también romper relaciones con taiwán en
medio de las tensiones con eeuu que
acusa el gobierno de nicaragua de
constantes violaciones a los derechos
humanos y que también repercutido en
sanciones económicas pasamos ahora a
hablar del reino unido- cómo afrontar a
este país europeo los datos históricos
de la inflación que está altísima y
bueno luego de conocerse el anuncio de
la oficina nacional eastick a británica
en el que reportó la inflación en 10 1%
comparado con el 2 por ciento de ese
mismo período pero del año pasado el
gobierno empezó a hablar de algunos
planes para enfrentar el aumento de
precio aunque todavía no se conoce una
política clara lo que se espera es que
el gobierno apruebe un paquete de ayudas
por 44 mil millones de dólares y el
ministro de finanzas aseguró que su
departamento estaba trabajando para
ayudar a los consumidores a cubrir los
crecientes costos sobre todo de la
energía y dejar el camino despejado para
cuando llegue el nuevo primer ministro
de esta forma reino unido- se convirtió
en el primer país del g7 en el grupo de
las siete economías más grandes del
mundo en tener una inflación superior al
10 por ciento ya hablamos ahora de
polonia y ucrania países vecinos que
reabrieron sus fronteras supongo en
términos económicos el intercambio
comercial es definitivamente bueno
después de haber estado cerrado por lo
menos un mes uno de los cruces
fronterizos más importantes entre
polonia y ucrania se reabrió nuevamente
desde que parte del este y sur de
ucrania fueron ocupados por las fuerzas
rusas luego de una remodela la terminal
ahora podrá recibir hasta 30 buses
diarios se aumentaron también el número
de carriles para camiones de 4 a 10 y se
crearon pabellones adicionales para el
control de aduanas y pasaportes dentro
del proyecto llamado frontera abierta
ambas naciones europeas habían acordado
aumentar la capacidad de tránsito de
este cruce fronterizo en al menos un 50%
la cifra del día para el cierre
557 euros por megavatio/hora ese es el
precio récord que alcanzó la energía
eléctrica en alemania para los
suministros del jueves según los datos
de la bolsa europea de energía aunque el
costo por megavatio ahora ya había
alcanzado los 500 euros esta semana hace
un año hay que recordar costaba 10 veces
menos rondaba los 50 euros el aumento es
drástico o 'jorge muchas gracias por
esta actualización del mundo económico
es todo por el momento en este bloque
informativo de directo américa a
continuación el debate